[MUSIC  PLAYING]
STEVE BAZYL: Hi, everyone, and
thank you for watching today's
GDL on Google Drive.
And today, we're announcing
two features for the
Google Drive SDK.
One is a little tiny feature
that you might find
interesting.
The other one that I'm going
to spend most of the time
talking about is a really cool
feature for helping users
discover content that they have
in Drive created by your
app a lot easier.
And this is custom thumbnails.
One of the nice things in the
Drive UI is the ability to
visually navigate your
Drive content.
This is really important if
you're navigating through
photos or if you have a lot of
content that was very visually
focused, charting,
presentations, things like
that, where seeing an image
representation of that content
is a way for users to identify
that they're actually using
the file that they want.
So actually, I have up
here the Drive UI.
And you can see I'm just in List
view right now where all
we see is really the title and
just the icons for the
applications.
But when I switch over to Grid
view, I get this really nice
visual representation
that I mentioned.
So I can see that for the
images, I've got a nice little
preview, same for documents
and PDFs.
But then I have this
other doc here.
And this is actually a chart
that I created with one of the
Drive apps--
Lucidchart.
And all we can do in this case
is just show the icon for the
application.
And as a user, unless I name my
files really well, it's not
really helpful for me to know if
I have a whole folder full
of these files, which is one
that I really want to work on.
And part of the reason why we
don't show thumbnails in this
particular case, we
don't actually
have the file content.
They're using a feature of the
Drive SDK that we call
shortcuts, which just allows
them to put a pointer to some
files that they have stored
in their own database.
So it would be great if they
could actually upload an image
that would help the user,
like myself, identify
that content quicker.
So now we can do that.
I'm going to switch over
to some code here.
This is actually just the Ruby
QuickStart that we did a
couple presentations on
these a few weeks ago.
And I modified this to allow
us to upload a thumbnail.
This is actually very similar
to how an application like
Lucidchart that is using
shortcuts would go about
creating a document.
I'm not going to go through
the entire code here, just
because we've already been
through these before.
I just want to focus on the
actual changes around in
serving the file data.
And I've changed a few things
here from the QuickStart,
mostly changing the MIME type.
This is the MIME type
that we use when
we're creating a shortcut.
And I also inserted some
new properties.
And these are properties
you'll find in the
documentation now on the file
resource that allow us to
upload a thumbnail.
In this case, it's
really simple.
It's thumbnail.
And that has two properties in
it-- an image and a MIME type.
Image is a Base64
encoded image.
In this case, you can see
here earlier we're
just reading a thumbnail.
It's a PNG file.
We Base64 encode it, set the
MIME type appropriately, and
then execute the request
as normal.
In this case, because I'm doing
a shortcut, I remove the
code to do the multipart
or reasonable upload.
I'm just putting metadata in
there, and life is good.
If this were a real application,
we'd also want to
do some other things for
shortcuts like uploading
indexable text.
That way, if somebody's doing a
search and there are certain
keywords in the content that you
think might be helpful for
a user to navigate their
content, that would make it
available to Drive as well.
But for here, we're just
focusing on thumbnails.
And what we're going to do is
just run this really quick.
Select my account, authorize.
And if all goes well, we should
have a response back
that says it inserted
the file.
One thing that's really worth
noting here is it doesn't
actually return the
thumbnails.
Thumbnails are a write-only
property.
So you can't read them back.
But what we can do now is
go back and see the
file that we created.
And here it is as well.
So now when we're in Grid view,
we actually get the
image that we uploaded.
This was actually the same
Lucidchart presentation that
we just had the icon
for before.
In this case, I just took the
PNG version of that, and I'm
using it as a thumbnail.
So really easy feature to use.
For applications that are
using shortcuts, this is
something that everyone should
be doing, particularly if the
content that you have has
a very strong visual
representation that's
helpful for users.
You can think of this in a lot
of other contexts, too, even
in cases where we're storing
the content.
There are a lot of different
formats that applications use
that we just simply don't have
the capability to generate
thumbnails ourselves.
I can think of something
like an MP3.
You might want to do album art
as a thumbnail for better
visual navigation.
For things like CAD drawings,
where again we don't have the
logic to render that, the
application can do a preview,
a very quick rendering of
that, different charting
applications with proprietary
formats.
Really anything that you think
would be helpful for users to
identify that content, upload
them as a thumbnail along with
things like indexable text so
that content can be very
easily discovered by users.
A couple of catches with
thumbnails, of course.
I mentioned already that these
are write-only properties.
So you can't read back the
thumbnail and try to download
it other than--
well, yeah, you just can't.
The other thing is that,
depending on the file type,
you have to be careful about
how you maintain
the thumbnail images.
For shortcuts, maintenance
is actually pretty easy.
Upload the thumbnail, and then
whenever there's a significant
enough change on your
application to that content,
just do an update on the
metadata to upload a new
thumbnail image.
With binary content, where we're
actually storing the
content in Drive, the thumbnail
is actually removed
in our system every time
the content changes.
So it's really important that
if you are providing
thumbnails, that every time that
you change the content
for a particular file, that
you also upload a new
thumbnail for that content.
It may be the same thumbnail
as you uploaded previously.
But it is important to keep
making sure that we have an
updated copy any time that
content changes.
There are some other
restrictions in terms of the
size of the thumbnail.
We do recommend the larger,
the better.
There are different ways that
these can get done.
If it's too small, you're only
going to see a very small
image on the screen.
But if it's too big, we're going
to downsize it anyway.
So there's a maximum width
of about 1,600 pixels.
About 2 megabytes for the image
size is about where
we'll cap out as well.
Most image formats
are supported.
Generally, we recommend doing
formats like PNG, but GIFs and
JPEGs are also fine.
Other formats will work, but
just not recommended.
So it's a really easy
feature to use.
Again, it's a couple extra
fields on the file metadata
when you're uploading or
inserting or modifying a file.
Really valuable for users to
make the experience of your
app and your files just blend
in a lot better into Drive.
So that's thumbnails.
Again, this just went
live today.
There's actually a blog post on
the Google Apps Developer
blog that you can go and read a
little bit more or find this
in the documentation that just
went live probably about 20
minutes ago.
There's one other small feature
related to this that I
want to point attention
to, and this is
additional image metadata.
We launched probably--
maybe a month or so
back, some new
properties on the file resource.
We had this image media metadata
collection on files.
And we haven't really done
a lot of presentations or
talking about this.
It's not really featured heavily
in the documentation.
But for a certain class of
applications, these are
actually really useful.
So previously, we had some very
basic information like
the width and the height,
geolocation information about
that photo.
And this is also that's
taken from the XF
data in those images.
And this is pretty useful if
you're building a photo
browser that's integrated
with Drive or any
sort of media tool.
If you're building a photo
library management tool, I
would personally love to see
somebody build something like
an Aperture or a Lightroom
that was backed by Drive.
I'd probably be the
first customer for
something like that.
So having width and height is
really useful if you're trying
to do screen layout and you want
to basically pre-lay out
the images while you're loading
up the thumbnails or
the full-resolution images
asynchronously.
But we also just recently
exposed a lot more of the
metadata, things like the
camera make and model,
exposure time, aperture, the
lens use focal length, and so
on, which is all really useful
information that people who
are very into their photo
editing may want to see that
information.
But we can actually preparse
that information for you so
you don't actually need to
download the full version of
the image, parse it, extract
the XF data in order to
display that.
So this gives you a way that you
can get that information
to the user very quickly just
by reading the metadata from
the files, while in the
background, you're loading
either different resolution
thumbnails to progressively
load or waiting for the full
version of that image to load.
So not a feature that's useful
for all applications like the
thumbnails, but it is
something that for a
particular class of application
that we're seeing
a lot more of, which are these
photo management apps and
image editing tools, this is
a great feature to take
advantage of.
So that's really it for today.
We actually do have some other
features that we're planning
on announcing very soon.
So keep tuning in to the GDLs.
And I think either next week
or the week after there's
actually some more parts of this
coming along that I think
are even a little bit
bigger features.
But it's all really cool
stuff, and we're really
excited to see what people are
going to do with this.
If you're building an
application and you're using
shortcuts, jump on the
thumbnails right away.
And if you're using any of these
apps for Drive yourself,
expect to see developers
start to adopt this
feature very quickly.
That is all for today.
As always, you can find
us here twice a week
and on Stack Overflow.
And we're happy to answer
whatever questions you have.
Great.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]